la journée s'articule autour de
plusieurs tables rondes et la
présentation de projets innovants issus
de travaux menés à l'hôpital de garches
avec des industriels comme cette
plateforme mobile pour handicapés quand
on cherche une solution pour des
patients ont essayé de voir ce qui se
fait déjà en commerce
et après s'il ya besoin de détourner de
l'améliorer on va chercher les
industriels qui ont développé cette
solution
le design et l'ergonomie peuvent
contribuer au bien-être des patients le
parrain de cette journée olivier lapidus
et designers et à créer des tissus
lumineux il s'est aperçu des bienfaits
sur des malades -notamment sur la
jaunisse du nourrisson je me suis rendu
compte du potentiel important de la
demande des malades et des handicapés
pour avoir du design je parle avec une
dame sur une chaise roulante qui me
disait que c'était formidable maintenant
la façon enfin l'évolution même du
design de sa chaise donc là ces
designers premier degré mais aussi la
recherche comment est ce que recherche
et design peuvent s'associer et comment
est-ce que des métiers aussi différents
que la mode le textile et l'hôpital où
l'on garde peuvent se rejoindre
par moments des innovations que l'on va
retrouver dans la vie courante comme la
fameuse télécommande de télé conçu au
départ pour les personnes handicapées
d'autres projets très concrets comme ce
kart biplace qui permet à des personnes
en fauteuil roulant souvent accidentés
de la route de retrouver la sensation de
conduite et de vitesse un vrai projet
industriel mené à mantes-la-jolie la
suite d'un accident s'aperçoit
psychologiquement les gens sont très
atteints et quand il remonte dans un
engin de ce genre ils ont vraiment
l'impression de pouvoir reprendre un peu
je dirais eux mêmes les rênes et de
vivre des sensations qui pensaient ne
plus pouvoir vivre cette journée fut
l'occasion de faire se rencontrer
handicapés chercheurs élus et
entreprises pour mieux prendre en compte
leurs besoins des personnes handicapées
devraient avoir plus la possibilité
d'être écouté